[DUCKS QUACKING]
JEAN BELLAMY: This way.
Turn around.
Good boy.
I've been riding since
I was 5 years old.
I really wanted to
continue that passion
when I got here to Princeton.
And the equestrian
team gave me that.
We have so many
people on this team
who have never seen a horse
before they got onto the team.
And our coaches are really happy
to teach you from step one,
like, here's how
to handle a horse.
Here's how to get on,
and then all the way up
to people who have been
riding for 15, 20 years.
ASHTON PHILLIPS:
Following your horse.
But you're sort of following
the trajectory of the horse --
I knew that riding
and horses were
going to be a part of my life
immediately after school,
whereas a lot of the
Princeton students
don't necessarily have that
ambition, although they
do very often want to
keep riding in their life.
For them, I think
it's a great outlet.
It's a bit of a
break from academics.
It's an opportunity to get
to do what they love to do.
And hopefully, many
of them will continue
with horses in their life,
regardless of what career
path they ultimately choose.
-- or sink and let them walk.
NIKOLAY SUKHOV: My work
is very theoretical.
I mostly sit and focus on the
formulas, like, all day long.
And this is a really
very opposite thing.
You're not focused on
something specific.
You're just enjoying the ride.
It really teaches you to
be patient but diligent.
ASHTON PHILLIPS: Excellent.
JEAN BELLAMY: When we
come out on weekends,
it's really a full day of
handling horses in a way
that we don't when
we're just riding.
We have to muck stalls,
and do hay, and everything.
And it's really good.
It shows you both sides of
riding, which is both, like,
this really fun exercise
riding part of it
and also the horsemanship.
You've still got a
noseband though, big guy?
ANNE STEVENS: We want
them to be confident,
because when you can start being
confident around a 1,200=-pound
animal, you can be confident
in most aspects of your life.
Those that really
embrace it, you
can see them grow year
after year in their ability
to deal with situations that
make them uncomfortable.
[KISSING]
JEAN BELLAMY: You're good.
I love being on the team just
because it's a good release
to get off of campus,
and to be around animals,
and spend two or three
hours every week just
hanging out around horses.
It's wonderful to be able
to decompress like that.
And I would say that my
academics have really, like,
benefited from it,
because I'm not constantly
studying and stressing out.
I get to come out, and really
relax for a little bit,
and do what I love.